so this is what you write down from the
definition of best principles and you
think here first principle I've totally
got this in the bag and then you look at
this and you like yeah it's a big bag
what are you going to do with it
how can you even start to work with this
even but this one was different from the
ones you did before you're like oh it
was fairly obvious that you can put
these pressures together and that's not
hard when you look at this though it's
more confusing because you don't even
know what to do with these two like one
of the fundamental things you learn
about irrational numbers is that when
the thing underneath the radical sign
out or is called by the way the square
root sign and radical sign the thing
underneath there it is very different
and they they're not like terms and they
can't work together you're right they
can't work together unless you mess with
them so I want you to remember if you
get given something like this then
there's a fairly standard thing that we
are all trained to do in your turn okay
I can write that fit plot what would you
do you would rationalize the denominator
right rationalizes wrote it up means x
won't do it ruin fire plus root tree and
I heard that important word conjure here
it's the same pair of serve but you just
swap the sign that's all what on earth
is that useful why do I do conjugate
tapas out here
very good so on the denominator here we
now have a minus B a plus B and then
you're good to go from there because the
difference of squares will square out
the surge then they can work together
and as some of these going to have to
happen here so I'm going to need to
multiply by the conjugate
okay now once we do this you can see
what's going to happen you write the
limit again on the top just watch out
for the subtraction there even though
end up looking that much I like to put
each of these terms
in brackets so I remember actually be
the two in Holdings the other time what
has each bead square what are you going
to kind of get on there's an idea of it
well is it just these guys right like
there's no way to really collapse them
down together so I'm just going to write
the whole thing but they are adjusted in
all the other examples of first
principles that you've done you can see
what's going to happen on that numerator
right you can see this guy is going to
play ball with this guy leaving you with
that H on the top that you wanting to
search accordingly so therefore this is
what you're going to get now please
don't miss this step please don't miss
this step don't see oh I've got to get
those HS er they're just going to
disappear ah that's a bad idea
two reasons another one I'm looking for
you to demonstrate that you know what's
going on don't skip this step it doesn't
take you long so right even with the
limit know like okay technically those
students who frequently say ah it
doesn't matter I'm just going to
eliminate it in my head because I see it
can be at the top bottom about 50% of
time instead of writing 1 and 1 just
what cancels they just say all the age
doesn't matter
so then writing a one day right at zero
because they say it doesn't matter which
of course lands you in a lot of problems
so I'm going to write this now I could
cancel here's the last time I write the
limit because at this point and this
point only I can actually evaluate at H
equals zero
I'm not actually doing it but I can see
how it behaves so this is one on this
like so on which leaves you with
okay now there's your gradient function
you want yes just like with the
hyperbola I'm going to ask some
questions of this and I'm going to use
limit notation to do it so for instance
what is the limit
considering this gradient right as X
approaches infinity what's the limit of
this function look at it so many things
to explore the denominator right it's
just going to get bigger makeup there
you go so what happens when denominator
to get a peak the whole thing gets
smaller it tends to zero so this limit
is you never actually gets there though
right never actually gets there for what
this means is it slows down forever
okay what about this look now I'm going
to write as X approaches zero
but these two among you will notice
there's a domain restriction of this
right in the domain restriction on this
just like there's a domain restriction
on this so therefore you can't just
approach the error from any direction
you like you could will be approached
from one direction which one you get the
only approach from the positive
direction because you can't supply
negative values of X into that matrix
what is the limit as X approaches 0 from
the way
what's happening what happens to this is
your 8 told me what happens when the
denominator gets being now after you
know what happens when the denominator
gets small what happens to the whole
fraction it either purchase acidity
doesn't it which is sort of what we
should have expected because we all know
what the square root of x function looks
like it looks like that right so you can
see yeah look there's that behavior gets
shallower each other I've actually drawn
too much
it's sort of grounded on there you go it
does increase forever but it's
approaching zero
and here at the origin you can see the
gradient is approaching infinity
because in fact the tangent here I've
already done it before my answers okay